bye baby I'm not gonna see Matty for
whole week
did you know there's a secret and fire
that reacts only
all the muffins to a place we desire are
we sure this
Simon's New York I got to the hotel took
a 20-minute nap headed to a rehearsal
for an event that has to do on Thursday
and now I'm heading to a little youtuber
reception for the creator summit so I'm
sure I'll vlog there everything does not
fit in the tiny bag
to find the leader what's number two
ladies real lady I'll do whatever
the cabbage okay morning everyone this
is Dave two or three in New York it's
super early and I was out really late
last night and now I'm at YouTube space
in New York which it was more awake but
so I get for saying not late it's my own
fault
I just wanted to get to the vlog behind
the vlog behind the vlog and yeah it was
a really I'm using the camera is a
mirror way so Joey I didn't get a chance
to ask you know after yesterday how was
the hypnotist oh my gosh
it was oh I'm so like processing how it
felt basically it was almost like I was
like conscious of everything that was
going on but I was just free it was like
when you're drunk gradual like falling
into it or ya know Asbury wasn't so who
you were drunk but not yeah that's what
it was like yeah I was really
embarrassed when I saw the photo it was
I I could not even contain myself like I
was crying so bad like I had to go back
and like wash my face cuz I had makeup
smeared I was die get off the roof get
in here
we're going to bring them out so you
work thank you I just started knowing
about there is no above like a cup of
room temperature water from the bathroom
you want a cup of water okay let me see
what I can do did you crash your drums
in here like what happened what did you
miss this are my dreams
watch you either crash drone or not
crash I completely lost control of it it
just took off I survived after and I
found it they had landed like politely
like a lost kid yeah I need a rock the
Highlanders on the roof of hotel that I
can recognize the roof of the hotel from
the gravel on the roof wait you've been
on that Bowery the middle I can stand I
told
I'm really sad my battery died of course
in my camera like always I usually carry
five extras but I did it I'm never
getting our photos to get in front of
and as check side we just rang the
closing bell that's incredible it is
cold we're heading over to break ass now
it means a brand cast and we're gonna
check out rose she has a little pig
station
it's amazing it's Child's kitchen
because she has like the courtyard and
then she hung all of her two times three
pots and pans and it kind of reminds me
of it it's so freakin cute
this was my absolute favorite video who
in the whole world
some people are